[Music]
[Applause]
robert orry one of our favorites joins
us courtesy of bet online check out bet
online for up to date lines on the nba
finals finals mvp finals prop bets and
uh you can get that for each and every
game robert good to have you back on i
know that uh you have a nickname big
shot bob is there a shot that you didn't
make that still haunts you to this day
oh yes man it's a shot that cost me six
million dollars
if i make this shot in my last year as a
laker in the playoffs we indeed we
planted spurs in san antonio um i had i
had an awful playoffs i'm not gonna lie
i shot the ball i think i was like three
for 39 from three or something i was i
was terrible
and we were in san antonio in their
building kobe drives kicks it to me i
miss that three so we go down 3-2 in
that series we go home and we lose that
game and the lakers don't you know
re-sign me next year and that would have
been my big year i'd have made six
million dollars that yesterday that shot
cost me a lot of money
uh give me your thought on the mindset
of jimmy butler i know you're a better
three-point shooter than jimmy but the
mindset of wanting the ball in that
situation game on the line down two
and he takes the three-point shot even
though he's not a good three-point
shooter you know you have to look at the
way a guy's playing the game and jimmy
was rolling um he looked at him at the
previous game he was rolling and for me
when you have your superstar the guy
who's the heart and soul of your team in
your building
um i'll let him take that shot anytime i
i think the only thing i would have
changed i'd have told him to slow down a
little bit because in my mind he was
going a little too fast slow down you
know gather yourself a little better and
take that shot because if you look at
the shot
everything was online the form was good
but he came up short and i don't know if
that's because he didn't
take any time out so he didn't you know
he played the entire game yeah and i
don't know if that little fatigue
because if you look at his his legs his
lower back was good
but his arm was a little short he didn't
extend as much as he should have so i
give him that shot any day of the
weekend but how do you do it where you
slow it down in a moment where you feel
like you have to speed up because the
game is on the line and the ball is
reversed to you
but in your mind you got to kind of
gather
but we think
get the shot off
you know it's it's a it's a mental thing
and i think when you watch a lot of guys
who make big shots like you know stef
lebron they don't worry about the time
they do their form you go through your
normal routine and you shoot the ball
because if you think in time
you're going to shoot the ball in a rush
or you're going to do something that's
out of ordinary for your shot and i
think with jimmy even though that was
not his ordinary shot if you really
break it down frame by frame you can
point out two major mistakes he made on
that shot for me
i don't i don't worry about i don't
think and that's the biggest key you
can't think when you're going to take a
shot down the stretch like that because
you know we do this motion a million
times in a week it's shooting the ball
so many times so you know it should
become you know a part of you
well i watched you know when ray allen
hit that shot with the miami heat
against the spurs like stepping back
like knowing where you are on the floor
to step back
and not step out of bounds or not step
on the line understanding where you are
on the court i mean
that's what makes that shot so crazy yes
it's in traffic game on the line
gather step back
and then know that you're in the
position you're gonna win the game yeah
that's why he was the number one
three-point shooter for a long time
until steph passed because his awareness
his ability to understand where he is on
the court and that's why those lines the
hash marks and everything on the court
and think about it ray knows how long
his the length of his step is he knows
that he knows where that line is and
that's his awareness and the iq of
players we don't talk about that sense
of guys you know almost knowing you know
the the shape of the floor how many
steps is needs you to get back and these
guys able to step back and take these
shots you know not even looking down you
know they know exactly where on the
court by the angles and the measure the
measurements on the floor so you know
that shot that ray allen made was
incredible also you want you want to go
back and look at some other guys who
like rasheed wallace and everybody
having a foot almost stepping out of
bounds if you go back and you look at
that shot that uh the miami heat i can't
think of the name
the three-point shoot i think that was a
good three
i think his foot was above the line and
he didn't step on like it's the shadow
that was on the line so you know we can
debate that for years we gonna have to
have one of those cameras like the
football players have you know the end
zone camera yeah where you can see down
the line and see if his foot was really
online i i gave him a three max strews
yes yes yeah
uh we're talking to robert dorey the
lakers analyst uh your thoughts on
bringing in a rookie head coach given
the situation with your los angeles
lakers you know at one point every coach
was a ricky coach and they have to you
have to give them a chance um you look
at tyler tyler's first championship he
was a rookie coach and nobody's talking
about that and i think a lot of people
is looking at the makeup of this team
you got strong-minded individuals with
lebron a.d and russ would darving ham be
able to handle this group i think so
because when you have the statue and the
makeup of a darving ham players are
gonna you know pay attention because
think about it if i put you in a dark
alley and you see darva ham come around
the corner
you go run the other way and so and i
think that has a lot to do with i think
he has he's been around the game a long
time he's played the game he's coached
the game and i i think a lot of guys
respect that if you look around the
league most of the most respected
coaches are guys who've been involved in
nba from playing and coaching for
a long period of time and plus you know
he was my pick from day one i thought
either him or sam cassell was my picks
and i think darva ham because of his
ability you know to bring in another
player eventually down the line maybe
for the lakers it might be a plus for
them i just wonder bringing in darvinham
into a situation where lebron j or older
a.d
is fragile
and i got russell westbrook who can't be
the player that he once was
and i can't change him you don't have
depth you don't have money with the
salary cut like it this is a pretty i
wanted i was hoping that darving ham
would get in to a better situation for
his first head coaching job
you know i i agree with that but still
though think about this if he goes
everybody's looking him to go into the
situation to fail
what if he gets these guys to the
western conference final is that
success for him does that like wow now
he looks that much better it's so many
times we look at things in a negative
like well this is not a good situation
from why not he got a.d if he's healthy
one of the best players lebron one of
the best players ever played this game
if you able to get some pieces or you
know trick some people say hey yo take
less money come play two years get your
championship and then we get you know
and that's that's going to be up to rob
palinka to get guys to come in but i
think when you got three guys like that
that that dominant they can stay healthy
you might be to you know surprise some
people and
darving ham good situation great great
players to play with but they just got
to stay healthy so don't go in the
situation thinking negative for diver
ham go in a situation thinking positive
that he can bring something to this team
because if you think about it you watch
darby ham play he played with the
ferocity and the nastiness if that can
carry over you know that can be great
for for the lakers how do the warriors
not win the championship
uh if someone gets hurt
you know if someone's getting hurt or
you get the young the new 2.0 splash
brothers meaning you know tatum and
brown to play it you know extraordinaire
but if it's a great matchup though you
know if you look at these two guys you
know brown is that guy you don't know
what you're going to get each and every
game he's gonna hit threes or he's gonna
get to the pocket he's almost like a
poor man's clay clay is a better
three-point shooter but clay can't get
to the bucket like he used to be due to
all the injuries but i think it's it's
gonna be a good series uh people
thinking the splash brothers with
draymond gonna have an easy cakewalk
because of all the leadership and
they've been there done that before
don't count on that because if you look
at the celtics and the way eme who is a
rookie coach who took over a team that's
almost like the lakers was and got him
to the finals you know what i mean so he
made one of my teammates i play with the
spurs you know i'm i hate to say this as
a laker guy but i'm kind of rooting for
him you know guys that i play with i
always root fight there's nobody on that
team i play with over there on the
warriors team so i had to root for email
because there's only me so many guys
that i played with still involved in the
game so
i think you know austin might look up
and win this thing because they got some
young guys who don't know no better what
i mean by that is they just gonna play
you know they ain't worried about who
i'm not supposed to win i'm not i'm so
they're just gonna play
you played with akeem
played with shaq
played with duncan
i'm not gonna include kobe in this the
question i'm gonna have is you can start
your team with a keem shack or duncan
you know it's you have to give me a year
in their prime i get you know i i love
dream i love dream but
you know he was he's always going to be
the better player of the three but if
i'm a starter team i got to go with shaq
because shaq is just so freaking
dominant you look at the yeah he won mvp
i don't think there was a person in the
world that could guard him you know you
had to you know go in a lab and make up
a player to guard him he was just so
dominant you know for that one year you
know but if
if i have to go for longevity i have to
go with dreams i know everybody you know
in san antonio thinks i'm gonna i said
antonio because i don't pick tim you
know tim is a hell of a player but for
me the guy who took me on his wing and
mentored me the guy grew up loving you
know hakeem elijah why i have to go with
him i'm not going to take tim dunn
because he's younger than me i ain't
going to
i tell people that tim duncan has a
great sense of humor he's he's a funny
guy but he never ever shows it
it's dry as heck yeah if he lets you in
it's he you're going to see a great guy
but it's you know that window is small
you know you have to be a tom brady to
fit that pass through that hole really
and that's tim you know if he lets you
in your circle he's really cool but then
you got to stay in that circle by doing
three things you got to play video games
you got to play poker and you got to
talk about cars if you don't talk about
those three things you would be out the
circle
oh
you know uh people have shack stories
where shaq would come out on the floor
naked
with just his shoes on yes you you can
confirm that
i could confirm that we sit there
and we we we're getting ready for a
playoff game i think we're gonna play
portland and we like we hold it up in
center corner everybody like where's
shaq oh he's getting treatment and then
next thing though he comes running out
there with his shoes on butt naked you
know like you know trying to light the
move because
you have to have those moments man you
know sometimes you can be so intense and
you have to have someone to like to move
but shaq is funny you know even if you
show up you know if you look at rick
fox's uh instagram you see one picture
where rick sitting there doing the
interview and shaq pulls his pants up
into his butt crack and standing with
his butt next to rick so you know he was
just a fun guy but you know a lot of
guys don't know how to turn it on and
turn it off but shy could go from the
clown to the killer in two seconds
if you could have uh you could have
barkley's career or your career
uh you know due to the fact that mark
barkley made more money than me
i take the money no you know i'm just
kidding i'm kidding you know this you
coming to this game about winning and
for me
to win seven championships in 16 years
and it is an incredible run um
you know even even though i didn't make
as much money as barclay i would take my
career in a minute because that shows
you it's not about the money for me i
think you made more than barkley did
well no paulie check and see what robert
made
i don't want to call out robert's
finances but i have charles barkley's
career salary
at 44 million dollars okay i made more
money than charles i take my career
that was easy yeah you know you know the
only thing i have to say is that charles
did have one thing i do wish i would
have you know my i only had one goal
coming up as a high school that was to
make the um olympic team and i thought
my best opportunity was in 1992 and all
of a sudden the dream team comes in i'm
like man what happened to the college
students that was me that was my goal
and so charles took that dream from me
so that's why i still even though he
went to auburn there's two strikes
against him right now waiting on that
third
i know you're joining us courtesy of uh
bet online what is the best bet
for the nba finals you know for me uh i
think the best bet will regard the
celtics because you got to go with the
odds um i think you know the celtics
are are are 13 they have a plus
130 in this game and for me you know why
not go with the odds and because here's
the thing
golden state doesn't have a deep bench
the celtics is a team that don't know
they're not supposed to win they got
tatum probably one of the best young
stars out of john moran that can go off
with 50 points at any point you know and
you know it's like
go go with the odds man go go with
yourself that's what i would do okay if
i said long shot mvp you know we we saw
this golden state team with iguodala
winning the mvp years ago is there an
iguodala that you could see winning this
longer odds yes you know the guy who
really saved them again the dallas
series uh wiggins okay andrew wiggins
he's a 20 to one odds and i'm that
that's the one i would go because think
about you just take one guy to get high
and we know
the nba likes stealing still stealing
the mvp from steph curry
might steal it again but but you know
what though if they win it though
there's no way the nba's gonna say we're
not gonna give it to curry again unless
someone like you know wiggins goes off
for crazy points or or or you know my
the guy who i've always loved and klay
thompson goes off but
i i you have to play the odds man 20-1
with wiggins
great to talk to you again robert thanks
for joining us man you know it's always
a pleasure to talk to you thanks for
having me on that's robert dory lakers
analyst for spectrum sportsnet and
courtesy of bet online